[Music]
I'm Keith Olbermann and this is the
resistance
Anthony scare Moochie bye Felisha for
all the evil and mashin aiding and
scandal inside the trump administration
history may decide that this man this
guy playing the Joe Pesci role in a bad
road company edition of Goodfellas he
will be emblematic of the flotsam and
jetsam that rose up from the bilge water
of this country to serve this wretched
present fired per the Washington Post
because the president who explained how
to quote grab him by the [ __ ] while
wearing a television microphone and
being recorded quote did not appreciate
how scaramouche's references to
autofellatio and mf'er x' coat linked
them to vulgarity another indication of
trump's supreme personality trait utter
lack of self-awareness fired thanks to
the labyrinthine personnel process of
the White House before his official
start date a neat trick previously
accomplished by only to my knowledge a
friend of mine from TV and Billy Martin
the five-time manager of baseball's New
York Yankees fired so quickly that when
I arrived at this studio I brought with
me a news tip about scaramouche II and
social media and before I could tell
anybody about it he was out of a job and
the news tip was irrelevant and most
importantly fired because the new broom
brought in to sweep the White House
clean that is this week's new broom
brought in to sweep the White House
clean the new chief of staff general
John Kelly reportedly told trump to do
it especially in so much as scaramouche
II had boasted that he would be
reporting directly to Trump instead of
say chief of staff general John Kelly
obviously the problem there is and pick
your cliche trying to put the toothpaste
back into the tube or the sterile
Moochie back into the fandango or the
chaos back into Pandora's Box general
Kelly has succeeded only in underscoring
that this is an administration
constructed entirely out of chaos you do
not counter effect the sense of
instability by firing a communications
director no matter how unsuited
the job before his official start date
you counter the instability by stopping
the instability by stopping the man who
is the heart of the instability and for
that particular quality the poster child
of this white house can only be and
forever will only be Donald Trump and
even today's d scare mooching of the
White House the act to supposedly
counterbalance chaos and instability had
itself already been counter balanced in
the morning Trump welcomed in general
Kelly as chief of staff at nine forty
six in the morning with a line that
suggests the president still does not
have any clue where he is nor what
exactly he is doing there
the man who however briefly is the 45th
President of the United States told the
new chief of staff
his second chief of staff in the six
months and two weeks of his presidency
the new chief of staff who was about to
fire the new communications director who
replaced all the people who wouldn't or
couldn't take the position in the first
six months in two weeks who helped
himself necessitate the second press
secretary and the second chief of staff
the second chief of staff who promptly
turned around and fired him the root of
all this Donald Trump told general
Kelley quote we'll see you in the
boardroom laugh all you wanted scare
Moochie and the rapidity with which he
reaped the madness he had sowed but the
perilous life-threatening endless
madness of the man who was so briefly
his boss is not going anywhere yet and
every moment Donald Trump remains in the
White House with scaramouche II or scare
emoji free we are all in danger
resist remove peace